hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at the decline line
in the mcdonald gambit now the mcdonald
game it starts out with
e4 e5 and then the kings gambit with f4
my favorite opening in all of chess
after the pawn takes here knight to f3
pawn g5 bishop c4 and then g4 attacking
the pawn and we're gonna play
knight two c three now i did another
video on the accepted line so i highly
recommend you check that out if you want
to see the accepted live and that is if
the pawn takes on
f3
but in this video we are going to look
at what happens if black does not take
this knight on f3 partly because a lot
of you asked for it as far as a
requested video but also i think it's
better for black if they don't take this
knight on f3 so we're gonna be looking
at four specific lines so you can see uh
how that's gonna play out the first one
is knight to c6 we're also going to look
at bishop c5 we're going to look at d6
pretty common defense in the king's
gambits as well as bishop g7 now first
we need to think about what the threat
is that white has you know if you play
a6 from black which again they're not
going to but the threat really is knight
to e5 both the knight and the bishop are
attacking this weak square here on f7
which is only defended by the king so
this is what white is threatening so
keep in mind as we're going through some
of the variations this is what they're
up against even in this situation if
black wanted to be aggressive and try to
attack you know queen h4 you just play
pawn g3 hey the pawn takes but then boom
the bishop comes to
f7 uh this is going to be check king to
d8 and then all of a sudden queen g4 and
that stops the threat immediately you
know queen takes and then it comes back
to
g4 so the first version we're going to
look at is knight c6 you can see right
away it does stop that threat of knight
to e5 that we talked about
after knight c6 we're going to castle on
the king side definitely does it feel
like the muzio gambit another video
series that i've created both on the
muzio game but and the tripio muzu
triple muzio gambit definitely check
those out if you are interested in this
variation in the kings gambit but after
we castle on the king side the main line
is just for them to take our knights on
f3 we are going to capture with our
queen and then they have a few options
from here one of them could just be
knight to f6
okay well from here you can see that we
can take with our queen on f4 and so
they weren't really protecting that and
now we start to have a lot of pieces
lined up on some weekend square for
black yes we no longer have rf pawn and
our king is somewhat exposed because
they can always play something like
bishop c5 here and check our king but we
can come to king to h1 we still have two
pawns in front of it but black does not
have their g-palm which is one of the
weaknesses they have in this variation
and we have a lot of material the bishop
both the queen and the rook eyeing down
on this file uh just a lot of pressure
so i don't think knight to f6 is going
to be the best play for them another
option that they have is bishop c5 they
need to get more material involved into
the game counter-attacking in the center
of the board this is kind of an obvious
one because it checks our king so we
need to move king 2 h1 here
but then they could play queen h4 get
pretty aggressive and i think this is
the best play for black so if you're
looking this and say you know what's
optimal play how should black respond if
white goes into the mcdonald gambit i
think this is the best play uh black has
a slight advantage if they play the
moves correctly now from here white
should play d4 and the reason for that
is because black has a slight advantage
white needs to put black in his mini
opportunities so that they can fail and
from here it may make sense for black to
take on d4 with their bishop and if they
do this is a mistake because white can
now take back this pawn on f4
and from here we have a lot of threats
let's say they play
d6 and we'll look at some other options
as well
but now we have the move bishop g5 this
is attacking the queen we're starting to
trap this queen here even if they play
knight e5 which is attacking our own
queen well now we can take with our
bishop on f7 check they move their king
now we can come back bishop to b3
and yes they can take um our queen here
but then we can take with our rook this
is check they have to move their king
and now we're just going to come up here
with rook to f7 they continue to move
their king get in the center of the
board which is not where they want and
now we can take their queen on
h4 and this is going to be a much better
setup for white in the game so if we
come back here
i don't necessarily think that they're
going to be playing uh d6 i think that
would be a mistake another thing that
they could play is knight to f6
now this blocks off some of the threats
we have on the f file because remember
we were taking with our rook we were
attacking this f7 square the knight on
f6 does stop some of those threats
now we can come back to
g3 with our bishop attacking the queen
maybe the queen comes to g5 now we can
play knight's b5 an attack on c7 forking
the rook and the king so we still have a
lot of threats we can still play bishop
to f7 we can also play bishop c7
if we want to so a lot of threats that
we have we can also get our rook to the
center files you know d1
particularly if we wanted to so that's
what happens that's what we're kind of
setting up and hoping that they take the
bait if we play
you know pawn to d4
and they take with their bishop
now they should take with their knights
right here because it attacks our queen
and so we can't just come up with our
bishop intake on f4 we're essentially
forced to take with our queen on
f4 black is probably going to take with
their queen on f4 we're going to take
with our bishop our bishop is eyeing
down this pawn on c7 they're eyeing down
our pawn on c2 you can see we're eyeing
down this pawn on f7 uh with our bishop
and we also have the rook behind that
for uh protection so if you count up the
pawns black has six pawns white has six
pawns both sides have the bishop pair
but you can see
that black does have two knights so
white is going to be able to gobble up
some material here and they do have more
of an attacking presence but black has a
better um overall setup just from a
material standpoint and white has it cut
out for him because they no longer have
their most material their best piece
their their queen and so that's why the
knight taking on d4
is the crucial move because it forces
the queen to move and essentially
exchange off where if the bishop takes
on d4 well now we can take with our
bishop on f4
and we don't have to exchange our queen
and now our queen becomes a strong
attacker and our bishop can start to
attack their queen so that's why
we want to give them an opportunity
because remember even in this spot black
is definitely winning this is the
correct move order for them
but there's no other real option where
we can even put them in a position where
they can make a mistake d4 is kind of
our last ditch effort
okay so that was what happens if they
play knight c6 in the decline line next
we're going to be looking at bishop c5
now this does stop white from castling
on the king side so sometimes i feel
like
players are getting their dark skirt
bishop involved into the game stopping
what is a pretty common move for us to
castle here
but i think this is a pretty poor move
from black because we just have d4 it's
completely fine with us if we want to
attack the center of the board open up
for our own dark square bishop to get
involved into uh the game here if they
just come to
uh b4 okay well now we can even just
castle on the king side uh and we don't
even have to worry about a lot of the
threats yes if they take our night we're
going to continue with the same game
plan as before we take with our queen
and this is fine we don't even care
about our knight here on c3 and they've
moved their dark square bishop twice and
they're not really developing their own
setup
all of a sudden we have all of the
pieces that really what we really want
to get involved into the action so i
don't think this is the optimal play for
black so that's bishop to c5 i just
don't think you're gonna see it all too
often if you do just know it is a
mistake another thing that you could see
is d6 this is a pretty common uh line
that you'll see from black players uh
playing the king's gambit decline lines
just because they feel like hey it opens
up for the light square bishop to defend
this pawn on g4
but from here same thing we're going to
castle on the king side we don't care
too much we want them to take our knight
here that's completely fine
if they do take we continue with the
same game plan we have for other
variations we take with our queen now
from here they could play bishop g7
but then we're just going to take with
our queen on f4 because this pawn on d2
has not moved yet we just want to start
gobbling out material and also we just
put more pressure on this f7 square
right here so they could now come down
to d4 remember they have the threat they
have to worry about on f7 with our queen
rook and the bishop so getting material
involved attacking our keen yeah we can
come over to h1 now they could play
knight to f6 this is protected by their
queen they do have to just stop the
threat on this f file uh but again you
know white has a lot of threats they can
deal with this bishop on d4 also stops
us from coming here to
d4 with our pawn uh but we can always at
some point play d3 get our dark square
bishop involved into the game start to
put pressure on our opponent so the last
variation we are going to look at is
instead of coming to d6 if our opponent
plays bishop to g7
we're to play the same thing that you
would hopefully expect by now we're
going to castle on the king side
uh from here
main line is just for them to take with
their pawn on f3 we're going to take
with our queen
and knight to c6 from black now we are
going to take with our queen on f4 and
you can start to see the threats that we
have coming together and all the
variations that are kind of building up
to this where bishop to g7 makes a lot
of sense it fianchette is their bishop
it attacks the center of the board here
but because of the move order in this
particular variation it's very difficult
for them to hold on to all of the
threats that white has let's say they
played knight f6 remember the queen and
the rook are attacking
the f7 square
but now we can play e5
and how do they really continue from
here well they can stop it with their
knight they can't just move this knight
away because if they just you know come
back to
g8 or h5 we just come up here and that
is going to be checkmate so they can't
do that they could take the pawn on e5
but then after that we just take with
our queen they could come to e7 but then
we take on at c7 we're just gobbling up
more material here so none of those are
particularly good
they could instead of playing knight to
f6 recognize that that's not a good way
to counter they could play queen f6 but
now we have the thread bishop takes on
f7 they can't take with their queen and
say yes my my king's protecting it we
have the queen and the rook in this down
this is going to be checkmate for white
after a few moves there's no way for
them to
stop this threat here and so we know
that is not a viable option as well so
after bishop to f7 they really need to
play like king to the eight and then we
can play our queen to g3 this is a
discovered attack on the queen here they
can't take our bishop again because the
rook is protecting it so now we're
attacking the queen the bishop's kind of
safe here the king on d8 is not well
protected we still have a lot of pieces
involved into the attack we're going to
be getting our pawn on the d file
involved so our dark square bishop can
get bulb into the game you can see if we
bring our bishop to
g5 that would pin down the queen to the
king so we do have a ton of threats that
black has to deal with so hopefully this
gives you an idea of the threats in the
mcdonald gambit again early on for
black if you're looking at it and you're
curious how you should respond i think
the best play is for black to play
knight to c6 but if they don't uh white
can put a ton of pressure and even if
they do you hopefully now know the best
way for white to continue
to hopefully set up black for more traps
where you can have a lethal attack so
thank you guys so much for watching this
video if you have other ideas on other
openings or
just ideas for videos in general you can
let me know in the comments below but
thanks again for watching i'll see you
in the next video